hey welcome to the LM model lifestyle
I'm Nikki sir hey guys I'm Daniel and in
this video we're gonna show you how to
do male model poses with suits so let's
not waste any more time let's start
[Music]
mistakes mistakes make you strong hey
guys welcome back so after you watched
this video please remember to go and
have a look at Daniel's other videos
where he explains how to do a photo
shoot for beginners because that video
gives you the basics of how to pose how
to use your angles and turn different
ways for the camera yeah that's the
basics and it's called the male model
poses for beginners so in this video
we're gonna focus just on the suit
itself so the first thing that you
really need to know it's more about the
feeling than it is about the poses
alright so you can do the poses all you
want you know it's gonna look really
weird if the whole feeling is not there
right yeah so it is also important to
remember that when you do a photoshoot
like this for suits they are either one
of two ways that the client would want
you to pose first would be in a very
elegant and very
confident way Yeah right to showcase the
suit especially for something elegant
like this but then the other way that
they would maybe want you to close is
the more relaxed feeling that's usually
the suits that you were with some nice
sneakers where you also don't wear a tie
so it depends on what the client wants
and what the grief is of the job Daniel
yeah yeah so mostly the plans want you
to have an elegant gentleman that's
strong and confident kind of a look so
that's what you have to give them and to
do that you give them 45 degrees to the
left to the camera to the right and you
give them these angles where you stand
up straight no slouch she kind of you
see how this looks it just looks like
love yeah so you stand up straight event
with the poses there's a few things you
can do if you don't know what to do with
your hands put one hand in the pocket
all right the other one you can put it
here inside your jacket like it's like
you're taking out your phone or
something
[Music]
or you can check your watch a little bit
or you just look around a little bit
lick to the left look down look up all
these kind of poses come play together
but what you have to try and focus on is
you have to be the person that is in
that suit so imagine that you're at the
office or if you're at an event yeah and
another thing that's also good is if the
photographer maybe doesn't have any
props or something with them you can
also use your own initiative to think of
something for example what does look
good on a very professional confident
businessman if is like something like a
briefcase or a kind of coffee those take
away cups a newspaper so if the
photographer doesn't have something like
that or the clients make the eyes thing
listen to you have a magazine or do you
have a newspaper because that also gives
that little bit more of the effect of
the businessman
confidence yeah yeah especially if
you're doing a test but if you do if
you're gonna work for the client then
they're gonna have their own ideas
already in place so you just you just go
you do the photo shoot
[Music]
but apart from that there's three things
that you need to remember as well and
that is the distance that a photographer
is away from the model right if they're
sorry gone
they usually shoot three different ways
they shoot the full body which is
usually in landscape and might also be
sometime sometimes in portrait painter
usually shoots hot body
how much is little bit zoomed anymore
[Music]
and then also sheets up close because
they want to get the details of the
things like the color or the shares
and then with the full body they want to
give a little bit more the pants how
they look the shoes it's a chaplains
always remember when photographers
standing a little bit further away they
are usually shooting full-body okay then
that little bit closer or when you see
them do their hands like this you know
okay those ooming in a little bit more
yeah and then if they do zoom in a lot
and your expressions very very very
important
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if it's far away then your whole body
all the movements is important now some
models when they start they struggle
because now they think of that hand so
they forget about the positions of their
feet or you know so with experience you
will get there so I'm going to show you
a few examples of walking so you can
just see how that's done
so sometimes you walk straight to the
camera or you walk straight
45 degrees left or 45 degrees to the
right now for me as experience model
there's something else I do so I start
in one direction but I kind of walk in a
kind of how do you feel like the arch as
well because that just makes it more
interesting and more real as well
[Music]
and then while you're walking though
just look at the camera all the time
look left everybody down make them make
it more interesting the more variety you
can give to the client the better model
you will be
[Music]
[Music]
okay guys and also remember that when
you do the walking purses always have
the leg that is the closest to the
camera that really needs to be straight
yes yes one beans yes the other one
bending if you see if the photographer
shoots a little bit closer so it's a
half length and she gets the top of your
ear legs in this shot then you can turn
your legs around because then it looks a
little bit more interesting and it gives
it that feeling of more movement but
apart from that the best poses are
actually the poses that you're not
posing at all where it is standing and
looking somewhere or walking and looking
somewhere those shots are the natural
nice shot
[Music]
the posing shots yes but you can see
they're very static and very so what you
need to do is basically have your suits
on it's actually so cool that I've got
mine on today and just do the normal
stands and and relaxed poses that you
would when you're in a normal situation
have your color and make it flowy moves
then move fast too fast and just move
with the clothes itself feel the color
things like that yeah yeah exactly
alright and this sometimes just forget
about the camera don't even think about
it because then you look really natural
the days where you do these kind of
poses and you just focus on doing the
post so good looking unnatural those
days are gone
[Music]
alright you get it right alright so
those poses you do not want to do just
think naturally walk naturally Stan
Walker naturally look around naturally
right and when you think to put your
arms your all your hands in your pockets
a lot of the guys that I've seen before
I put the Hat the hand in the pocket and
then it crinkles yeah jacket yeah yeah
it messes it up a little said so doesn't
it yeah it doesn't look good in the
video that we did you'll see that
sometimes Daniel puts his hand in his
pocket and then he looks at the jacket
and he straightens to jacket so that's
very important too if the cameraman and
the client sees that you do things like
that it also counts as brownie points
towards your professionalism because
they can see that you know what you're
doing ya know 100 percent it's a lot of
models forget it's not just about you
the photo shoot is about the clothes
you're wearing or the product you're
selling so you have to present that in
the best way
right say [ __ ] it's awful the model that
is where the model needs to look good
but it's when you do a job the job is
all about the products remember that
yeah now when it comes to expression you
have to imagine that you're that person
so imagine you're walking you to
business meeting right now you have that
confident kind of look sometimes they
want you to be more friendly more smile
more inviting so then you think about
things that make you happy for me
something to think about my wife
yes is the photographer answers also my
wife so it's like double points for me
anyway you get what I'm saying so
imagine that imagine that role it's a
little bit more like acting
and abort important tip that I can give
you guys if there's specifically
photographers watching is remember to
shoot from a little bit over lower angle
when you shoot suits because the lower
angle gives them all of Jacek look to
the model as well as the clothes broader
shoulders slimmer hips and slimmer legs
and looks very nice alright guys that's
it for this video if you liked it give
it a thumbs up subscribe and we see you
in the next video choose
[Music]